This program is broken in to a series
of milestones, or a series of projects,
that are built to introduce you to
the major paradigms, major ideas,
in machine learning.
We're going to start
with the big picture.
We're going to start with some materials
that cover the entire landscape
of machine learning and
artificial intelligence.
Then we'll get into model building and
validation.
Machine learning is really about
building models that describe data and
then validating them
against some metrics or
comparing them against one another.
Then we'll get into the nuts and
bolts of machine learning.
We'll cover supervised learning,
unsupervised learning, and
reinforcement learning.
These are different tools in your
toolbox that can be used to address
different kinds of problems.
And that's important, because machine
learning isn't just about being able to
use a certain algorithm or
do a certain technique.
It's about knowing when to do it and
how to evaluate the results.
Those are the real learning goals
we want you to come away with this.
We want you to know how to do certain
machine learning techniques, but
we also really want you to
understand when to use them.
And towards that end,
at the end of the nanodegree program,
you're going to take
on your own project.
You're going to take on your own
problem that you want to address
using some of the techniques
that you've learned.
You're going to decide what is
appropriate for this kind of problem?
What is appropriate for this question?
What techniques should I apply?
And how do I evaluate the results
that I get out of it?
Because you're choosing that project
yourself as well, you'll come
away from this nanodegree program with
something that no one else can claim,
a contribution that no
one has made before,
a real testament to your
mastery of machine learning.